[Music]
all publicists have the same strategy
first you do 60 minutes when you're
selling a book and then you go on the
view to talk about what you said on 60
minutes you saw that happen with the
former FBI director and now you're
watching with his deputy Andrew McCabe
he was in 60 minutes the other day and
now he's taking a victory lap around
America's media landscape and
predictably he was on the view today to
justify the do Jay's plan to spy on
undermine and perhaps overthrow the
elected president United States here's
part of it you understand how far we had
been pushed to even to even have a
conversation that included those
statements we were all operating under
incredible stress we were all grappling
with this idea that we have a president
who we think may have committed
obstruction of justice who we think may
in fact be a threat to national security
what do we do in this circumstance
because Russia one man who likes the
sound of that idea is University of
Minnesota law professor and dumpster
fire expert Richard painter is endorsed
the idea of having the cabinet invoked
the 25th amendment to remove the
president which a painter joins us now
professor thanks very much for coming on
good to see you tonight
um so to see how would happen with this
work would I was obviously never been
attempted this is not the kind of
scenario it was designed for but in your
mind how would they remove the president
by force with firearms Nats I mean how
would this play out practically speaking
well first talk I want to tell you
wearing a great tide and I love you
having the University of Minnesota
colors there I talked about the 25th
amendment number of times with respect
to this president it was put into the
Constitution late 1960s to address a
situation in which the president is
physically or mentally incapacitated
unable to carry out his duties rain fest
but we know what it is how would but how
would you effects it how would you do it
presumably the president wouldn't
concede
being overthrown so would you rush into
his office would you rouse him from bed
like how would you do this no there's no
you don't overthrow the president none
of that this is not an issue with the
president there are thousands of
psychiatrists who have voice of extreme
concern about president promise you get
some compliance ranks to agree he
shouldn't be president sure you probably
at 99% of them to say that I would not
be spotted to the 25th when I do the
cabinet the majority of the cabinet and
the vice president could temporarily
remove the president from office but how
they grew happyto
physically removing that's not what's
provided for the Constitution physically
removing him from an office the
objective is to have the vice president
of the United States take over the
duties of the president temporarily
while the president for example would
get a psychiatric exam and then the
United States cause so you're always
rushing around we need 24 the men
the president says I'm not crazy I don't
want to leave I was elected by voters
two years ago I'm not leaving and then
you do what if the majority of the
cabinet the Vice President were to
temporarily remove the president then it
would be up to two-thirds of the United
States House and Senate to permanently
remove the president under the 25th
amendment but they psychiatric okay exam
at a time look think this through a
little bit come back and we can play it
all out because you just started you're
only just leave some how's it with the
cool fluid of reason if you were rich a
painter you don't need the dumpster fire
for this no I know you don't know you
don't we're out of time unbelievably
could go on forever